i couldn't care less about the pluto
nonsense it's not even a planet who
cares i am not a planetary scientist but
i could not help but get swept up in the
excitement it felt like such a worldwide
event you know it was all over social
media it was all over twitter you could
follow the spacecraft live on nasa tv it
is funny astronomy makes the news in a
really disproportionate way to every
other science and so actually
there's always something exciting going
on in australia but you i think you're
right that actually people have this
sort of fascination with planets um or
not planets depending on your
perspective when it comes to pluto and
so actually yes when when you get to see
a new world that no one's ever seen
before i guess that does generate a
degree of excitement that you don't get
from most astronomical discoveries
because it's about as exciting as a
little block of ice in my freezer it's
it's just not it's not a planet it's
just a rock it's not important what what
science are we going to learn from pluto
nothing in my opinion so
it's it's to be honest it's just padding
to the americans
what's it got to do with america well
wasn't it an american that discovered
discovered pluto this is what i as a
child of the 1980s grew up with the
national geographic picture atlas of the
universe and i must have memorized most
of this book this is in my childhood the
best image that we have of it and the
blobbiness of this image is
what indicated to scientists that pluto
had at least one moon do you think it's
a planet
i don't care i really really don't care
i was actually so this was voted on by
the international astronomical union a
few years ago and i was a member of the
iau and i could have actually gone along
and cast my vote
and but
it why why does it matter it really
doesn't matter very much right i mean
pluto is still pluto it's still the same
object that it was what you choose to
call it in some fairly arbitrary way
is not science in any real sense of the
word it's just an arbitrary definition
of we'll decide this many these ones are
planets and these ones aren't so the
moon is this little lump on the side
and if if there's any mystery left to
pluto it's how you pronounce the name of
that moon because at the new horizons
press conference you heard about half a
different have a dozen different ways of
pronouncing it so i'm going to call it
sharon because that seems to be one of
the standard ways but i'm sure people
will disagree with my pronunciation of
that if tomorrow someone came along and
said
andromeda is no longer a galaxy all the
other ones we're going to call galaxies
but andromeda is going to have some new
classification i can imagine you having
your nose out of joint because you're
into galaxies
i would but the reason the only reason
my nose would be out of joint is because
actually there are good physical reasons
why andromeda is like
m33 and various other galaxies that
there clearly is a commonality between
them right in this case it's just an
arbitrary judgment call there's clearly
there's some kind of sliding scale
between things that we call planets and
things that you'd call kuiper belt
objects
and
pluto is somewhere in that sort of gray
area where you're going from one over to
over to the other but it's
which which side of that boundary you
choose to name it really is completely
arbitrary it's a riddle gravity
yeah maybe four percent of earth's
density less than ice mass about
one-sixth of our moon
core unknown what is it it's actually
bad for science to get hung up on this
right because actually it gives the
impression that science is all about
really rather subjective judgments
um and and arguing over over the names
of things arguing over classifications
rather than actually understanding how
plant you know the science is about how
planets form and if you could show that
pluto had formed in some fundamentally
different way from the other eight
planets in the solar system then then
i'd be very happy that really that you
should give it a different name at that
point but until we actually understand
the science of that level what you
choose to name it really is pretty
arbitrary
and arguing over the name rather than
arguing over how planets form is i think
sort of counterproductive to science but
i thought pluto was different to the
other planets isn't the argument that
maybe pluto was a captured
object if we if we understood that and
knew that then maybe i'd be happy to
give it a different name but you know if
i look through the solar system and say
you know if you can play a
mercury and jupiter
you know they're both planets and yet i
would say that mercury and jupiter are
more different than mercury and pluto if
you just look at pictures of them so why
we've decided mercury and jupiter will
call those planets but pluto which
actually looks quite like mercury isn't
the planet until you as i say until you
can come up with some science behind it
to justify why actually that really is a
fundamentally different type of object
then then just giving them different
names is rather misleading because it
suggests they are intrinsically
different objects before we really know
they are um and as i say it sort of
detracts from the science which is the
fun bit of trying to figure out how the
solar system formed in the first place
and this evidence that was used against
pluto which i believe is the clearing of
its orbit like it hasn't hovered enough
stuff out of its orbit that seems to be
what cost pluto its planet status you
don't think that's science
it at some level it is but for example
you know you can look elsewhere in the
solar system and you can say actually
jupiter hasn't really hoovered out its
orbits because it's all those
trojan asteroids which kind of more or
less share jupiter's orbit actually
because jupiter's rather massive it sort
of anchored them there so
it looked like one of those examples
where there was a reverse engineering a
definition which allowed you to for
whatever reason decide pluto wasn't the
planet anymore i think what was going on
is they started finding these more
distant objects like arius and so on
further out and there was this worry
that suddenly we'd end up with a solar
system with 300 planets in it which
would just confuse everyone and so they
wanted some definition that would allow
them to cut off the solar system more or
less where it was and unfortunately the
definition they came up with also cut
pluto off when you're talking about
particle physics you're talking about
the nitty-gritty of science you know
you're stripping everything back and
learning about the sort of the core of
things where things really come from at
the most sort of raw naked level
i mean it it's sort of like the ultimate
truth really this is why particle
physics is so beautiful why it's so
dominated by things like symmetries and
things that are so elegant perfectly
well i said historically okay we'll call
the solar system everything that was
discovered before 1950. you know and
then pluto would have been a planet but
you know they chose not to do that but
it is just a matter of definition that
does seem less scientific well yeah i
guess so but except it's it's sort of
more justifiable than that it actually
well i guess that's reverse engineered
as well isn't it just kind of get the
answer you wanted but yeah it's but it's
all pretty arbitrary i think the other
thing that we found out in the bigger
picture
is the diversity of objects in our own
solar system and so this idea that there
were nine classical planets well that
that's changed dramatically over the
years you know
at one point we thought there were 16
planets you know it it just depends how
you count them it gives this impression
that science is about stamp collecting
you know how you choose to name things
and all that and the fact that it can
change you know that the pluto used to
be a planet and now it isn't makes it
just seem science very arbitrary and
that means that when you translate that
into other fields like
more contentious ones like climate
change and so on it gives it gives this
impression that actually scientists are
just making these arbitrary judgments
and actually any judgment you choose to
make is perfectly valid just because
well my arbitrary judgment is at least
as good as a scientist's arbitrary
judgment whereas actually you know real
science isn't about that sort of stamp
collecting side of things it's an
important part of science right we have
to collect data we have to categorize
data and so on but if you get so hung up
on the categorization that means that
you're actually shortchanging the
science you're not actually moving on to
say to answer the interesting questions
like how did the solar system form did
pluto form in a different way from the
rest of the solar system i think that of
course it's impressive that we can that
we can we have the technology to do
things like that um i just don't know
pluto's where i would have gone
where would you go i don't know i love
saturn and we just i just hang around
saturn
yeah yeah yeah
yeah just do a bit more because people
have an emotional attachment to the
planets they learn them in you know in
infant school they learn the names of
the planets and so actually people get
very upset when you suddenly say
actually no that one's not a planet
anymore so i think there is that sort of
emotional angle to it which there isn't
in most areas of science and that as i
don't think that's helpful to science if
scientists seem to be arguing about that
it's fine it's you know i'm happy to
argue about it over a pint of beer but
it's not it shouldn't be seen as a
scientific argument at that point
you have a you have a son i don't know
if he's going to become an astronomer or
not i've never i have it very much yeah
what do you tell him about pluto on the
planets
pretty much what i've just told you
actually that you know whether you
choose to call it a planet or not
doesn't matter to pluto pluto is still
the same as it was so it really doesn't
matter what you choose to call it you're
like son i want you to make your own
decision about the planet absolutely
yeah do the astronomers know how you
feel about pluto
um
i don't know maybe they feel the same
about pentaquarks who knows you should
ask that
tony told me this morning he thought
this visit to pluto was incredibly
boring and it's just another rocky icy
thing and it's nowhere near as
interesting as a lot of other stuff
going on in science why is he wrong
um just
look at look
just look at that image
look at the surprises that that image
brought up
you know this is a this is a world that
is changing
changeable it's got an atmosphere it has
snows it has surface features it's
hardly got any craters which means that
that surface is somehow refreshed
um
yes this is this is not something that
i'm going to be writing papers about but
how can you not look at that picture and
and be amazed
i'm team solar system i'm team solar
system is turning out to be a much more
interesting place than having simply
nine planets that's so boring just
saying oh we've got nine planets we've
got a much more interesting solar system
than that pluto plays an enigmatic role
in that whole system
whether it's planet or not i don't think
makes a difference